television and social media usage are at
all time Highs but sadly anxiety
depression and loneliness only seem to
be worsening with time there's a thing
called the negativity bias which is our
tendency to become more affected by the
negative experiences that we have rather
than the positive ones so when we watch
the news and we watch horrible things
happening around the world it shapes our
perspective of the world this constant
receiving of negative information about
how humans treat each other and treat
the world is often what leads people to
believe that there is no more good in
the world but when you intentionally
surround yourself with positive people
and nurture friendships that motivate
you to be a better person and also cut
off these negative news feeds what are
you left with positivity so while the
rest of the world may be focused on how
horrible the recession is going to be or
that the zombie apocalypse is coming you
instead are out having coffee with a
friend that motivates you to work on
that project you've been meaning to work
on instead of focusing on the things
that you cannot change